Nên thành, người dân khốn cộng cụ cố gữ, vì chân trạch tranh đôi về ông nghiệm môi trường.
Thưa tạp chỉ lột sự Việt Nam, sự khu dân cụ sống tên ina, thuốc sát tiến thành,
về in thành, một chân trạch tranh đôi xa suốc gia cầm quy mồ lớn đa gầy ông yếm.
Nếu tại từ chân trạch, chưa được sự li đang có sấu hiệu sạch tiếp ra môi trường.
Cô thị, theo các khổ sân tại đây và nãy, chân trạch về ông nghiệm này thuốc xác điểm của ông
lay văn hơn, tại sống tên ina, sát tiến thành, về in thành tình in an.
Đức sây dịch tự cách đây hơn mười năm, chủ yếu tranh đôi các lệ xa suốc gia cầm nghiệm
lần, ra, vigt. Huyên tại ông hương đang tiếp tục cho xe tếm để mở giọt quy mồ sấu lượng.
Cũng trạch và nánh của ông nghiệm, chân trạch tranh đôi của ông lay văn hơn,
đặc hiện cho cuộc sống của ông nghiệm dân sống xung quanh bị xa ổ,
huy hơi thôi lan ra từ trạch lượng, anh hưởng đến xức khỏe, kê ra bệnh tật,
đất vuyền trong gia đình cũng không càng tất được, sau biện hưởng từ việc ô nhiễm, có giúp nhiều dưới mỗi,
không chỉ ổ nhiễm không khi, chất thải thây trạch còn khiến nước xin hoạt quân những hộ dân xúc quanh
liện mùi hồi thôi, muốn nước xin hoạt bị ổ nhiễm không sự dụng được.
Dếm nước xa đến cũng bị giấm bình.
Cũng theo tập chỉ lật sự Việt Nam khi hỏi chính quyền định phương về công tác quản đý và bảo vệ người dân,
tì có trả nơi được lãnh đạo ý bán nhân dân dân sản tình thành lưu ra,
là trước tây đại cho kìm tra và sự phạt thành chính hộ dân ở lệ văn hơn vì hành vi gây ổ nhiễm.
Và vừa rồi, sau khi người dân phản ảnh, chính quyền sả kép tục kìm tra lãnh hai,
tuyên, khi phòng viên yêu cầu được tiếp cận quyết định sự phạt,
thì việc lãnh đạo này không cũng có, và lấy lý sau quyết định đăng được cả mộ trên một dữ sẽ cùng cấp sau.
Không hiểu với lý sau gì, sức miếng năm qua, chủy chẳng trạch tranh môi này vẫn bất chấp quy định pháp bật,
trong khi chính quyền định phương không thể xử vý quyết định để bảo vệ người dân.